I'm a twelfth day of Christmas my
Truelove said to me nothing because I'm
single and alone
[Music]
hey everyone my name is Matt ballasts I
and this is wide about it a weekly video
series where I get drunk at my desk and
complain about stuff on this week's
episode the worst things about office
holiday parties because getting
blindingly shit-faced front of all of
your co-workers is an art form that
should not be left in the hands of
amateurs who cannot handle this
responsibility
so let's drink not too bad alright
[Music]
alright first of all getting drunk with
your co-workers is literally the
definition of a recipe for disaster
whoever decided to mix people who have
to work together in a professional
setting every single day with a raging
gurgling waterfall of alcohol is a
sociopath who wants to expose your life
for the hot-ass mess it truly is Oh what
could go wrong let's just throw a bunch
of people who've repressed their true
feelings about what another every day
for the last twelve good months into a
room together instead of bull vodka in
the middle of them I'm sure no one will
die or go down on someone who's married
even though he'd never really talked
about his wife that much at work doesn't
have any pictures of her in his office
also office holiday party food is
garbage nobody in the history of eating
has ever actively sought out a shrimp
cocktail
oh are you hungry here's a bunch of fish
in a cup with some spicy ketchup you
piece of [ __ ] then the next day everyone
is always like wow I wonder why I wonder
why Carol threw up all those martini
olives cuz you got her drunk and all you
fed her was a single cracker a toothpick
of cheese it
cube of sweaty unidentified meat of
course she was in wasted while you fed
us with table crumbs next there's always
that one person who you know is gonna
make a [ __ ] fool of themselves every
year why are we having parties when we
know the same person is guaranteed to
get wasted after two drinks grope
someone next to the punch bowl then
violently throw up two pigs in a blanket
why are we letting this happen every
year it's always someone named Randy or
Hank but also during during the holiday
parties everybody tries to act like you
can't let loose when you absolutely can
if you want
just cuz Randy decided to hurl up an
entire gingerbread man doesn't mean I
can't get the [ __ ] down with my funky
jolly self next what up do you have to
get dressed up to go to a damn holiday
party everybody already knows you look
like a [ __ ] mess you're not fooling
anybody fizzy wear a velvet tie and you
tuck in your shirt
you're still a piece of garbage now
you're just a seasonal garbage then
there's always that one guy who gets a
little too handsy busy thinks nobody
will care because it's Christmas and
baby Jesus let's go for it
well guess what douche can just because
Santa is watching doesn't mean you can
grind up on something so you can't grind
up on the other 364 days a year okay why
don't you just keep your Yule Log to
itself just keep it in its little Yule
Log pouch next there's always those two
coworkers who shouldn't hook up who hook
up and everybody has to look at it like
oh no they're doing it in front of all
of us they're doing it they're doing a
show someone should stop them so much
good stuff this tornado from happening
but we can't all you do is stand there
and watch while you deep throat one of
those pretzel sticks that's been dipped
in chocolate
with the sprinkles on
god I love those things and finally
holiday parties are the worst because
they always tell you it's an open far
and then they close it on you know the
bartender's always like sir I think you
have to pay for this bottle of champagne
you just chugged sir and then I have to
be like oh I'm sorry I don't speak
English and then he has to say Oh sir
you do speak English because I'm having
a conversation with you right here and
then I have to say no my husband he is
speaking that she paid for me and I
point to a stranger like double myself
you know Mike he indicated that's what
holiday parties are alright everybody
thank you for watching this week as
always you can find our videos every
week on whineaboutit.tumblr.com in my
page which is facebook.com/buzzfeedmatt
and that's it that's everything that's
all right thank you for watching Harry
Christmas
[Music]
you know would be how I ended my
Christmas parties I went to McDonald's I
got a McFlurry no Oreo McFlurry
I ate it in the back of a cab on the way
home I jabbed out on that [ __ ]
in the uber driver was like are you okay
sir and I was like yes